when I first visited bonus iris I
immediately fell in love to me there's
no city like this in the entire world my
name is Kristen Borg I'm a travel
enthusiast and a contributor for
National Geographic I first came through
here on my way to Patagonia taking some
time to explore poetess iris is one of
the best decisions I ever made
the moment you step outside you're
immersed in Argentinian culture like at
the delicious Koreas today I'm visiting
el Desna Bell this local Perea is a
traditional restaurant where open fire
drills are used to slow cook local
Argentinian meat into incredibly tender
barbecue
the smell is indescribably good and
permeates the air it was fun to get a
crash course and all the different cuts
of beef served and with all of the
Koreas to choose from across the city
you can find that hidden gem of your own
after lunch I always like to stretch my
legs and there's no better place to do
that than Palermo Park there's a reason
it's so popular with the locals and
nearly a thousand acres it has the most
open space that you can find in the city
centre from unique flower gardens to
boat rides there's so much to do and see
and I know I'll always have the perfect
backdrop for a beautiful photo off the
beaten path is estancia via maria an
old-fashioned hotel on a ranch places
like this are perfect to relax and catch
your breath we got to learn about
Gauchos here the Gauchos are legends in
Argentina they have a rich history
spanning back to the early 1800s helping
Argentina gain independence from Spain
their culture has continued to be passed
down over generations as they work as
ranch hands looking after horses and
preparing meals for the estate seeing
their way of life is an experience in
itself every time I visit Buenos Aires I
wish I would have stayed longer towards
the end of my trips I often find myself
waiting to return
[Music]